[Musique]
messieurs bonjour nous interviewons
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne youtube qui
s'appelle signe que review n'ont rien on
aurait aimé avoir votre point de vue sur
le pétrole et gaz de schiste l'évolution
des prix peut-être on va commencer par
nicolas meilhon nicolas meilhan bonjour
bonjour qu'est ce que vous faites dans
la vie alors je suis ingénieur conseil
chez frost & sullivan sur le transport
et l'énergie et à côté de ça dans mes
heures libres je suis demande de deux
think tank l'association pour l'étude du
pic pétrolier l'aspo et le think tank
les econoclastes mais très bien francis
perrin bonjour je suis président d'une
société de presse spécialisée qui
s'appelle stratégies et politiques
énergétiques et directeur des rédactions
de la publication pétrole et gaz arabes
et je vais laisser notre dernière
dernier les invités un dernière invitée
se présenter tout seul je vous écoute
qui êtes vous olivier un père j'ai fait
en fait toute ma carrière dans le
secteur de l'énergie depuis le premier
choc pétrolier
j'étais jusqu'à ces dernières semaines
président d'une
dans la playlist de recherche et
d'innovation dans le domaine de
l'énergie et maintenant je suis membre
de l'académie des technologies ge
participe aussi motion tank ifri et puis
président du conseil français de
l'énergie très bien on va rebondir sur
nicolas meilhan nicolas meilhan qu'est
ce que vous pouvez nous dire sur la
situation du pétrole 21e siècle quelles
sont les perspectives à court moyen
terme
alors aujourd'hui l'association du
pétrole pour faire rapidement
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation on
a une offre supérieure à la demande de
pétrole qui a fait baisser les prix
aujourd'hui on a des primes aux
alentours de 2 60 dollars 1 la question
que les gens se pose c'est de savoir
est-ce que ça va durer ou non
cela dépend de d'énormément de
différents facteurs 1 l'évolution de la
production de pétrole de schiste aux
états unis et surtout l'évolution aussi
de la demande de pétrole ce soit dans
les pays
comme l'europe mais surtout la chine qui
connaît actuellement un ralentissement
économique important si on s'intéresse à
plutôt à moyen et long terme on voit
qu'on a une hausse inéluctable des coûts
d'extraction du pétrole si on prend
l'exemple du champ de kashagan au
kazakhstan on est sur des niveaux à 125
dollars le baril du coup et on sait
aussi que on a un plafond limite à
partir duquel les gens n'achètent plus
du pétrole donc quand le pétrole dépasse
les 100 dollars vous avez de la demande
de pétrole qui est réduite monsieur ap
hm est ce que voulait rebondir ce que
sur ce que dit nicolas
je voulais revenir d'abord sur les
fondamentaux du pétrole d'abord le temps
de l'énergie c'est le temps long et on
voit que la part des énergies
renouvelables
ne peut progresser que très lentement
les estimations qui sont faits qui font
consensus qui ont été faites notamment
par l' agence atteint de sun l'énergie
montre que entre 1990 et 2000 40 la part
des énergies fossiles va passer de 80 2
% à 75 % malgré les politiques qui sont
mises en oeuvre donc le temps de
l'énergie et le temps long le temps du
pétrole et le temps long deuxième
fondamental
le pétrole c'est la géopolitique et
c'est andré giraud ancien ministre de
l'est de l'ain dustrit pendant le
deuxième choc pétrolier qui avait
l'habitude de dire que le pétrole est
une matière première à fort contenu
diplomatique et militaire avec une
valeur fiscale indéniable et
accessoirement un pouvoir calorifique et
donc quand on n'a pas intégré cette
dimension géopolitique du pétrole à ce
moment là on passe à côté de beaucoup de
choses
ce qui est vrai pour le pétrole est vrai
aussi pour le gaz comme les russes nous
l'ont rappelé récemment avec l'ukraine
troisième point quand on se concentre
sur le pétrole de plus en plus pétrole
égale transport transport égale pétrole
dire la totalité de l'accroissement de
la demande de pétrole dans le monde
provient du secteur transport le secteur
transport y compris le transport
ferroviaire le transport aérien c'est de
l'ordre de 55 % de la consommation
pétrolière aujourd'hui mondiale et cette
part augmente et à l'aide d'un autre
côté le pétrole un monopole un quasi
monopole pour le secteur transport 92 %
la consommation d'énergie du secteur
transport ce sont des produits
pétroliers donc il faut bien intégrer
ses fondamentaux quand on analyse la
situation du marché pétrolier ces
perspectives francis perrin la
géopolitique énergétique qu'est ce que
vous voulez qu est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire au jour d'aujourd'hui entre
la syrie l'arabie saoudite
tout 7 5 un débile à l'iml le yémen le
soudan le soudan du sud la russie
l'ukraine comme l'a rappelé
effectivement olivier appert l'instant
on ne peut pas parler pétrole en
particulier énergie en général sans
parler géopolitique ça ne veut pas dire
que la géopolitique explique tout bien
sûr le pétrole l'énergie c'est de la
géologie c'est de la technique c'est
d'économie c'est de la politique de
stratégie la géopolitique mais là par la
géopolitique est importante notamment
pour le pétrole matières premières
hautement stratégique c'est clair alors
évidemment par définition on est sur des
sujets pour lesquels on ne peut pas
faire de prévisions parce que les
évènements géopolitiques les ruptures
des coups d'état des tensions les
printemps arabes l'iran et beaucoup
d'autres choses ce sont des points
d'interrogation majeur lorsqu'on étudie
les marchés pétroliers
depuis les marchés énergétiques en
général mais cela pèse d'un poids
important cela a pesé cela pèse cela
pèsera ce qui est clair c'est
qu'aujourd'hui pour revenir au court
terme puisqu'on distinguer ses
différentes dimensions court terme moyen
terme long terme juste titre dans le
court terme eux pour l'instant la
géopolitique ne pèse pas beaucoup
ce qui ne ce qui n'a pas été le cas dans
le passé ce qui ne sera pas le cas dans
l'avenir c'est là on est vraiment sur le
court terme parce que comme le rappelait
nicolas meilhan on a encore un excédent
d'offre de pétrole sur le marché et que
un excédent qui se chiffrent à combien
de millions de barils alors là dessus
certains vont dire de l'ordre de 2
millions de barils par jour croit bon
c'est une apps et d'un ordre de grandeur
une approximation c'est parle chiffres
il ya différentes estimations possible
mais c'est probablement 2 millions
certains vont dire jusqu'à deux millions
cinq cent mille autres vont dire 1,8
million de barils par jour je pense que
c'est un ordre de grandeur qui me paraît
qui me paraît correct je confirme vos
chiffres par l'intermédiaire de feu
christophe de margerie
sensiblement les mêmes chiffres on est
sur des ordres de grandeur qui sont
assez partagés au niveau de l'industrie
pétrolière et puis les des observateurs
de cette industrie aux observateurs de
la scène énergétique
pour l'instant sur les marchés
pétroliers au sens vraiment les marchés
les bourses de londres de new york sur
lesquels sont fixés les prix du pétrole
les opérateurs les traders ne regarde
que cet excédent de l'enfant sur la
demande et donc certains pays où
certaines régions sont à feu et à sang
il ya une guerre en libye il ya une
guerre en syrie le yémen on a vu ce que
c'est irritant sion sans je ne dis pas
que ça ne joue pas du tout mais ça joue
très très peu ça n'a pas été le cas
entre 2011 et 2014 avec les printemps
arabes avec les tensions autour de
l'iran et prochainement évidemment la
géopolitique reviendra par la grande
porte sur les marchés pétroliers mais
actuellement mais on est uniquement dans
le court terme pour l'instant les
marchés pétroliers n'ont d'yeux que pour
cet excédent de l'offre sur la demande
et la question c'est quand cet excédent
sera-t-il résorber pas en 2015 est ce
que ce sera 2016 2017 2018 ensuite là le
débat le débat commence mais pas en 2015
parce qu'en 2015 la production nord
américaine
les etats unis canada tire à la hausse
la production pétrolière mondiale depuis
quelques années grâce au pétrole non
conventionnel le rôle de chief pétrole
de schiste aux états unis pétrole
extrait des sables bitumineux dans
l'alberta au canada donc sont deux
catégories différentes de pétrole non
conventionnel c'est un certain pierre
augey nous c'est le kérogène c'est lié à
ce qu'on appelle les schistes bitumineux
qui est encore une autre catégorie les
trois de l'orénoque alors l'orénoque
c'est du pétrole ultra lourd ou vénitien
c'est encore une autre catégorie en fait
on a au moins quatre catégories de
pétrole non conventionnel les schistes
bitumineux c'est pas d'actualité parce
que c'est pas techniquement
économiquement c'est pas techniquement
maîtrisée par dynamic man rempart contre
pétrole de schiste aux états unis ça
fonctionne à preuve le pétrole de
l'orénoque au venezuela ça fonctionne le
pétrole extrait des sables bitumineux
dans l'alberta ça fonctionne dans les
trois cas une production industrielle
massive parce que c'est rentable les
schistes bitumineux c'est du long terme
donc ça c'est hors du débat pour un
point le tout déplétion des gaz de
schiste et pétrole de schiste rapide pas
rapide ce que rapide par nature
effectivement très rapide par rapport au
pétrole ou au gaz conventionnel est-ce
que vous pouvez donner une échelle de
rapidité 6 me permettre de m'exprimer
comme ça c'est à dire le taux de
dépression s'est on parle en termes de
moins en termes de
d'année quelques années quelques années
on peut y avoir parfois mais évidemment
c'est difficile de quand on parle du
pétrole de schiste aux états unis je
crois que il ya une tentation à laquelle
il faut essayer de résister mais c'est
pas facile
c'est la généralisation
et la période actuelle de chute des prix
est très intéressante à cet aspect parce
que beaucoup de gens ont dit avec la
chute des prix et elle est considérable
le pétrole de schiste est mort aux états
unis le pétrole de schiste n'est pas
mort par contre certains producteurs
sont morts ou seront morts prochainement
parce que ce sont de petites sociétés
parce qu'ils sont trop endettés parce
qu'ils ont des coûts de production b
aujourd'hui encore en 2015
l'essentiel de la production aux états
unis de pétrole de schiste elle continue
même avec les prix dont nous avons parlé
aujourd'hui dont un brent aujourd'hui on
ne manque pas long de 60 dollars par
baril mais dès brut américain reste
texas intermediate qui sont en dessous
de 60 dollars par baril la grande
question il ya de grandes questions
c'est premièrement quel est le seuil de
résistance des producteurs américains de
pétrole de schiste à la chute des prix
du pétrole il ya mon avis il ne faut pas
les enterrer trop vite sinon les
producteurs de pétrole notamment les
producteurs opel vont faire une grosse
erreur et deuxième question si les prix
remonte parce qu'ils vont remonter la
question c'est quand et avec quelle
vitesse mais les prix vont remonter si
les prix remonte par exemple supposons
qu'il remonte à 70 dollars 75 on va voir
certains des producteurs de schiste qui
se sont retirés du marché qui vont
revenir sur le marché et donc ils vont
réaugmenter la production donc est ce
qu'à l'avenir les producteurs de schiste
aux états unis pendant en tout cas un
certain nombre d'années pas
éternellement ne constitueront pas une
espèce de plafonds à la possible de
remonter de la hausse des prix du
pétrole et personne ne peut répondre de
façon précise à ces deux questions
pourquoi puisqu'on n'a pas d' historique
la dernière phase de chute des prix
s'était 2008 deuxième semestre 2008 on
était en juillet à 147 dollars par baril
pour le brent et on est passé à 35
dollars en décembre
à ce moment là le pétrole de chine
faisait nuit c'était zéro quasiment
plusieurs années après on a à nouveau
une chute des prix du pétrole mais avec
des modifications majeures dans le
paysage énergétique et notamment
l'existence de cette production de
pétrole de schiste aux états unis qui a
permis aux états unis après 20 ans de
décroissance de leur production jusqu'en
2008 d'augmenter en 2009 en 2010 en 2011
en 2012 en ukraine 1-4 et encore en 2015
donc ça on n'a pas d'historique on n'a
pas de référence et on va voir on va le
tester mais je crois qu'il faut pas
aller trop vite sur ces questions là et
proclamé la mort du pétrole de schiste
aux états unis ce serait une grosse
erreur nicolas meilhan est-ce que vous
souhaitez rebondir oui alors les
chiffres
de rentabilité c'est ça qui est
intéressant de savoir à quel à quel
niveau le pétrole de schiste est
rentable le chiffre qu'on a différents
analystes et y compris du silo de chou
berger c'est à peu près 75 dollars donc
ça veut dire que sous 75 dollars en
moyenne et c'est difficile de faire des
moyennes vous perdez de l'argent
n'hésitez pas à interroger d'ailleurs et
c'est d'ailleurs le palier si finalement
partir duquel le pétrole de schiste
s'est développée aux états unis c'est
quand le prix du baril a dépassé les 80
dollars en 2011 la question est de
savoir effectivement le pétrole de
schiste américain avec la baisse du prix
n'est pas mort la question est de savoir
si oui ou non il a atteint son maximum
de production si on s'intéresse aux
chants du bakken dans le north dakota sa
production baisse depuis deux mois les
chiffres du mois de février sont sortis
il ya quelques jours et vous avez une
baisse qui ne peut pas être imputée un
phénomène saisonnier ok vous me rappelle
une histoire de hackers le new york
times l'avait exfiltrée 400 pages de
mails privés certaines sociétés
exploitant des des gaz de schiste et
pour avoir lu à peu près les trois
quarts de ses 400 pages les gens de
terrain était très inquiet quant à la
dépression de ce bassin alors vous avez
quand même sur les taux de dépression
n'a parlé quelques chiffres entre la
première année d'exploitation et la
deuxième année d'exploitation vous
perdez entre 60 et 70% de la production
donc ça ça s'appelle un taux de
dépression effectivement élevé la
question qui va se poser les gens vous
disent souvent le pétrole de schiste
américains ces deux révolutions
technologiques la la fracturation
hydraulique et le le forage horizontal
mais le pétrole de schiste américain
c'est surtout deux phénomènes importants
un prix du pétrole élevés au dessus de
80 dollars et surtout une politique
monétaire américaine qui avec ses
différents assouplissement monétaire
quantitative easing depuis 2009 à 1
flatter le prix du pétrole mais aussi à
encourager les sociétés allaient
investir dans le pétrole pour aller
chercher des rendements monsieur vapeur
oui là je il ya il ya beaucoup de choses
qui ont été dites et je vais peut-être
réagir d'abord la géopolitique n'est pas
morte faut se rappeler quand même que le
pic du pétrole le pic de
deux prix du pétrole en juin 2014
c'était hier c'était 115 dollars par
baril c'était au moment où la communauté
internationale a pris conscience que
dash étaient à 50 km de bagdad et là ça
pouvait poser des problèmes majeurs d'où
une flambée des prix alors aujourd'hui
il est effectivement paradoxal que le
marché n'intègre plus de tous ces
dimensions cette dimension géopolitique
dèche n'est plus à 50 km de bagdad mais
à 60 effectivement ça fait un changement
majeur je dirais comme vous le savez est
à 400 km de paris comme comme vous le
savez aussi la situation en syrie est
tout à fait calme en libye a un
gouvernement qui est qui s'est fait
faucher tout à fait calme au soudan ça
va bien les relations entre israël et
ses voisins sont vraiment pas s'y fier
donc c'est comme si on ignorait
complètement le fait que la situation
géopolitique aujourd'hui et qui au
moyen-orient le marché
si la situation géopolitique au
moyen-orient et plus inquiétantes
qu'elles ne l'étaient encore il ya six
mois ça c'est un point qu'il faut pas
qu'il faut pas oublier alors avec un
petit focus sur le moyen-orient
rappelant quand même un chiffre les
réserves pétrolières de pétrole
conventionnel je parle pas du pétrole
non conventionnel mais les réserves de
pétrole conventionnel sont localisés aux
deux tiers dans les pays de l'opep et en
particulier dans le golfe arabo persique
avec l'iran le
l'irak l'arabie saoudite les émirats
arabes unis le koweït est ce qui vient
valable pour le pétrole est aussi
valable pour le gaz est selon lui dis
moi donc ça n'oublions pas la
géopolitique parce que ça ne va nous ça
va nous revenir un jour ou l'autre
j'espère le plus tard possible sur les
aspects
révolution technologique en fait c'est
pas des révolutions technologiques sert
le la fracturation hydraulique dont on
parle à une crise depuis 1949 il ya eu
aujourd'hui 2 millions de fracturation
hydraulique il y en a 500 fracturation
hydraulique qui se font au qui se font
en par semaine aux états unis quant au
forage horizontal il a été les premiers
forages horizontaux ont été faits dans
le secteur pétrolier en 1981 donc ce
sont des technologies qui existent et
qui sont très largement qui sont
éprouvés est-ce que son encontre ce qui
nous vaut c'est qu'il ya une
industrialisation
de ses technologies avec des gains de
productivité qui ont été faits c'est pas
des technologies nouvelles mais c'est
simplement la façon dont les opérateurs
pétroliers dont les sociétés
parapétrolières ont mis en oeuvre ces
eaux mis en oeuvre ces technologies qui
a été ordonnée par un prix élevé du
pétrole si je rappelle que le shah
d'iran dans les années 70 disait une
fois que le prix du pétrole le permettra
nous irons chercher tous les pétroles de
schiste ou conventionnées avec un dj de
42 ans a débarqué puis le shah d'iran
il a dit hier que le prix élevé du
pétrole a permis ces développements
ensuite en raison des gains de
productivité qu'évoquer olivier appert
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
l'industrie aux états unis les pétroles
de schiste a besoin d'un prix de 100 ou
110 dollars ou 120 dollars ou 90 dollars
pour voir l'évolution le sur les coûts
effectivement on n'en sait rien il ya un
an tout le monde considérait que en
dessous de 90 dollars effectivement le
les pétroles de schiste américain
s'arrêterait ça se passe pas il ya une
réduction une réduction par 50% du
nombre d'appareils de forage en amérique
du nord depuis le mois de septembre et
la production reste stable à el bez
peut-être un petit peu si on est la
production de la production de pétrole
de schiste aux états unis ne reste
quasiment stable malgré une diminution
de 50 % du nombre d'appareils de forage
de l'état et un chant qu'elle augmentait
d'un million de barils par jour donc par
rapport à son rythme d'augmentation et
les contenus l'évolution du nombre
d'appareils de forage en activité ses
crocs bien voilà c'est par là les
progrès technologiques c'est le business
model est quand même tout à fait
différent du business modèle classique
de du secteur pétrolier les coûts de
lait par exemple la durée de forage a
été divisé par deux en cinq ans le
nombre de fracturation aussi ont trois
quatre ans a été multiplié par deux donc
il ya eu des progrès de productivité
considérables qui font que aujourd'hui
on peut produire on peut continuer à
produire même si les prix se sont
effondrés alors effectivement et alors
un autre point qui est important c'est
que il ya une très grande diversité
au niveau des coûts de production ou ce
que l'on sait des coûts de production
parce que là aussi il n'y a pas
forcément beaucoup de transparence entre
entre un opérateur un autre opérateur en
train gisement entre un bassin un autre
bassin entre un gisement dans un bassin
et un autre gisement dans un autre
bassin les coûts de production qui sont
dans les rapports on voit que ça varie
de 25 dollars par baril a éventuellement
sous 80 ou 90 dollars par baril alors je
me pose une question concernant la
technicité de cette production
le coût écologique
[Musique]
des gaz de schiste nous sur internet on
voit énormément de choses passent et
avec un contact direct entre les
populations et la question que je me
posais et dès que j'ai d'ailleurs posé
directement à christophe de margerie je
lui ai dit écoutez comme vous voulez
vous qu'on vous laisse exploiter ce type
d'énergie alors que vous n'êtes pas
capables de gérer les torchères en
afrique ça rien à voir ça n'a rien à
voir c'est à dire que vous avez des
torchères en afrique qui balancent
énormément de particules avec des gens
autour qui sont arrosés de particules
toute la journée
et ce scandale écologique qui est
écartée nos yeux parce que compressé
l'afrique c'est des sauvages en france
en france le confier ce type
d'exploitation à des pétroliers qui
n'ont déjà pas su exploiter correctement
technique c'est la question que je me
pose est ce que vous pensez avec votre
expérience dans le domaine que les
techniques de fracturation hydraulique
respecte
d'écologie
les techniques respecte l'écologie dès
lors que sont appliquées les règles les
règles de les règles de la profession il
y avait il ya une profession établi par
les règles de la profession sont
contrôlés par les administrations quand
elle existe et ça effectivement si on
veut contrôler si l'administration veut
contrôler elle est vraiment tous les
moyens elle a tous les moyens en france
elle a tous les moyens aussi aux états
unis alors mais les etats-unis comme le
nom l'indiqué ce sont des états unis or
les réglementations environnementales
c'est état par état et effectivement les
réglementations environnementales sont
très strictes dans certains états est
tout à fait comparable aux
réglementations environnementales en
europe elles sont moins strictes dans
d'autres états donc faut faire attention
quand même à
faut pas faire d'amalgamé
amalgame pas je me dis simplement que
unis l'industrie qui n'est pas capable
de gérer déjà des torchères et c'est
compliqué sur lac saint point important
parce que prenons le cas que vous venez
d'évoquer et prenons un pays comme le
nigeria un pays dans lequel une
proportion majeur du gaz associé au
pétrole et brûler parce que le gaz il ya
deux solutions soit vous trouvez du gaz
seul un gisement de gaz soit vous avez
un débouché vous allez produire vous à
les commercialiser au delà vous n'avez
pas de débouchés que vous n'avez pas
mettre en exploitation du gisement mais
souvent le gaz est associée au pétrole
des produits du pétrole et en même temps
fatalement vous produisez du gaz et si
vous n'avez pas marcher sur le gaz vous
n'allez pas arrêter votre gisement pas
ce que voulait produire du pétrole parce
que ça vous savez vous avez un marché
vous avez toujours à marcher pour le
pétrole et c'est ce qui se passe dans
des pays mais de nombreux mais comme le
nigeria la région du delta du niger dans
laquelle c'est un vrai effectivement
scandale d'écologie de meubles un
bourbier innommable effectivement tout à
fait il n'y a pas de marché local ou
régional pour le gaz les compagnies
produisent du pétrole et donc elle brûle
le gaz à la torchère c'est un gaspillage
économique majeur c'est le gaspillage
d'une ressource précieuse sur le plan
écologique notamment les pollutions
locales c'est déplorable pour les
populations et sur le plan de l'aide et
gaz à effet de serre du changement
climatique c'est évidemment absolument
déplorable également mais là c'est pas
parce que les compagnies pétrolières ne
savent pas faire ce qu'il faut c'est
parce qu'elles n'ont pas de marché pour
le gaz et que le gouvernement nigérian
joue un jeu très ambigu en disant c'est
affreux cet affreux cet affreux mais en
même temps comme il est le principal
bénéficiaire de la rente pétrolière il
laisse les compagnies pétrolières faire
ce qu'elles font depuis des dizaines
d'années si comme le rappelle olivier
appert le gouvernement nigérian c'est
aussi une fédération mais si
gouvernement fédéral disait maintenant
ça suffit vous arrêtez de brûler le gaz
associé des compagnies de se ré du jour
au lendemain
en quelques semaines simplement dans
certains cas elle fermerait certains
puis certains champs et y aurait moins
d'argent qui tomberait dans les caisses
du nigeria et quand j dans les caisses
du nigeria s'est pas toujours des
caisses de l'état nigérian c'est parfois
dans les caisses de quelques personnes
mais ça serait probable à des proches et
voilà mais c'est pas un problème
technique aux états unis vous avez
évidemment un marché sur le gaz
considérez vous avez des gazoducs
partout donc vous allez pas mettre des
torchères mais vous trouvez le même
problème en russie gasprom brûle
énormément de gaz associés c'est la
russie c'est pas mieux géré ya donc ça
ça dépend de politique d'état d'une part
parce que ce sont les états qui fixe les
règles du jeu quand vous avez un pays
comme le nigeria qui préfèrent regarder
ailleurs parce que l'essentiel c'est que
tombent dans les poches de l'état entre
guillemets une bonne partie de la rente
pétrolière au mépris des conditions de
vie de sa population dans le delta du
niger eh bien vous avez des compagnies
qui peuvent faire n'importe quoi depuis
des dizaines d'années si vous avez un
état qui fait son travail des
administrations qui font leur travail et
qui fixe des réglementations des
législations ils ont vous faites pas si
vous faites pas ça les compagnies
pétrolières ne sont pas des gangsters je
veux dire si on leur dit vous ne faites
pas ça eh bien elles vont trouver des
solutions et s'il n'en trouve pas ils
produiront pas moi je pense que quand
même sur le nigeria le nigeria l'angola
en face à saint trond 2 pays il y a
effectivement les gaz associés une façon
de valoriser ces gaz qui ne trouvent pas
de marcher localement c'est de le
liquéfier et donc le nigeria a investi
les compagnies pétrolières ont investi
pour liquéfier ce gaz et le vendre sur
le marché international ce qui réduit
d'autant le gaz qui est brûlé en
torchères ça mais ça reste très
important car la procession or il est
effectué sa coûte cher mais il ya des
les investissements se font les
investissements se font aussi en angola
donc assez politiquement correct de dire
que les pétroliers dit qu'on n'était pas
politiquement correct aujourd'hui non
mais c'est politique si vous êtes
politiquement correct en disant ça hein
mais il ya quand même des
investissements qui se fond
d'investissement qui sont lourds mais ça
fait quand même il ya ça fait quand même
une vingtaine d'années à peu près que
les compagnies pétrolières ont commencé
à investir sur des chaînes de
liquéfaction de gaz pour qui conduisent
à limiter voire eu un feedback en direct
du nigeria par des hackers nigérian qui
nous ont envoyé des photos de l'état de
leur bordure de vue face à ça c'est un
autre problème n'est pas lié au fait que
les lois ferry alors le fait qu'ils
aient du pétrole parce qu'il ya des
pirates qui perce les pailles pour
récupérer du 'pipeline' ils ont son
corps en le fait qu'ils aient une mafia
vous inquiétez pas on ouvre on est aussi
au courant leur plus gros problème
c'était les torchères quand même été
être éclairé jour et nuit voir cette
ressource partir en fumée il est
particulier saucier qui viennent on va
dire soulier et contaminer toute leur
chaîne alimentaire ça les rend d'air
relativement il était énervé quand même
et dans le ballet j'ai rien du delta du
niger moi j'ai suivi de près des
rapports notamment venant de d'amnesty
international il ya aussi une grande
partie qui lie à la vie du site et les
oléoducs
de shell est donc dans il ya une grande
partie dans les compagnies pétrolières
je ne parlais d'ailleurs pas que des
compagnies du gouvernement du g riant
qui à mon avis le principal responsable
des compagnies pétrolières notamment
chaîne
j'ai rien ont eu pendant des années un
comportement qui n'est pas du tout
conforme aux meilleures pratiques de la
profession de brion parce que bon le
delta du niger bomba seynois shell
évidemment pourrait pas se comporter
comme ça aux états unis au canada au
royaume uni parce que depuis longtemps
évidemment il aurait eu de très gros
problèmes mais il y a donc il met
toujours sur ce genre à des pirates le
mouvement pour l'émancipation du delta
du niger etc oui bien sûr ça existe dans
certains cas il ya nombreux taxis de
problèmes techniques au nigeria des
fuites par rapport à désolé ou de 9
heures parce qu'un réseau n'a pas été
entretenu correctement comme on sait le
faire mais là c'est pas une question de
d'incapacité technique est une question
mais là encore si on a un gouvernement
qui supervise comme il est censé le
faire le travail les compagnies
pétrolières et qui leur impose de faire
un certain nombre de choses les
compagnies elles vont vite comprendre la
leçon si par contre le gouvernement fait
passer le message qui n'a intéressé que
par l'argent du pétrole au détriment de
sa population il faut rappeler que le
nigérian moyens il est plus pauvre que
quand l'exploitation pétrolière a
commencé il ya plus de 50 ans entre
temps le gouvernement nigérian a touché
des centaines de milliards de dollars de
rente pétrolière donc où est passé
l'argent au nigeria mais encore pour moi
le principal responsable c'est le
gouvernement dans ce cas de figure quel
voeu pieux
nicollin moi je voulais rebondir sur la
fracturation hydraulique et l'écologie
je pense qu'il ya quand même un sujet
mais qui est auquel il ya des solutions
c'est la consommation d'eau avec la
fracturation hydraulique à l'eau puisque
en 2025 le rapport de l'onu prévoit que
deux tiers des habitants de la planète
vivront dans des situations de stress
hydrique et donc quand vous devez faire
de l'exploitation dans une zone peuplée
vous avez différents usages pour l'eau
ça pose un problème aux états unis vous
allez a besoin d'eau pour les deux
carburants pour la population pour le
gaz ou le pétrole de schiste et ça
aujourd'hui c'est un des points sur
lequel je pense devrions plus travailler
y compris en france il existe
aujourd'hui des techniques alternatives
qui ont été pratiquées notamment au
canada avec la fracturation au propane
ou à d'autres guides dérivés électrique
une note technique mais surtout on
compare nous avons eu un 2002 il trace
un sillon de la fracturation électrique
ou la fracturation thermique c'est au
niveau véritablement du laboratoire et
colas rien que la ce qui est étrange
c'est que si vous voulez dans le débat
du pétrole et du gaz non conventionnel
on est incapable en tout cas en france 2
le des passionnés de dépasser les
obstacles de dépasser les films comme
gazland alors je connais personnellement
je fox
le documentaire gasland est effet une
façon à mon sens non partisane c'est que
mon essence a bien sûr qu'il y ait eu
des cowboys aux états unis dans le début
du développement du pétrole de schiste
qui est fait n'importe quoi ça c'est
tout à fait possible et même probable
nous en france je me semble que la
fracturation hydraulique c'est des
choses qui ont déjà été pratiquée pour
l'expérience à un problème tellement
simple pour le gaz de lacq non c'est sûr
de nous surtout ça a été commencé pour
l'extraction d'uranium qui faisait
remonter à nager je tiens ça de
l'ingénieur au def il est remonté les
particules d'uranium grâce à ça mais la
fracturation hydraulique a souvent été
utilisé dans différents pays du monde
pour du pétrole et du gaz conventionnel
curieusement on en parle que depuis que
on parle de gaz de schiste et pétrole de
schiste une logique est complètement
classique donc en france en france il y
ait deux sans fracturation hydraulique
ont été faites et la dernière
fracturation hydraulique a été fait en
2010 dans le bassin parisien on n'en a
pas parlé ça a permis d'améliorer la
production vous parlez de gaz landes
j'ai lu avec intérêt
un rapport fait par la colorado holding
as commisssion il ya au colorado une
administration qui contrôlent
effectivement le qui contrôle les
activités pétrolières et donc qui a noté
que deux qui a analysé les cas qui avait
été présenté par gazland et qui montrait
que dans un cas effectivement c'était
une erreur qui a été fait par
l'opérateur et cette commission
administrative a sanctionné cette cet
opérateur dont l'un deux autres cas ce
n'était pas du gaz de schiste mais rct
du gaz biogénique qui venait en fait
d'aquifères
c'est cinq élevages parler leurs poils
je ne sais pas si les vaches perdre
leurs poils mais en tous les cas lorsque
la colonne colora de cette commission a
voulu rencontrer le réalisateur de gaz
landes il n'a pour lui expliquer il n'a
pas souhaité les rencontrer c'est un
petit peu un petit peu j'ai écouté j'ai
serré le jeu tiendra rapidement et
d'avoir sa réponse
colorado le and gas commisssion très
grand plaisir je voudrais revenir à
nicolet meilhan qui développe un peu
plus son ce raisonnement autour des
modes de transport qu'est ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire l'évolution des
modes de transport qu'est ce que ça va
donner avec une population qui croît on
va dire à 2% par an alors comme le
rappelait très bien olivier appert 1
l'automobile met d'ailleurs depuis le
début du 20e siècle c'est l'application
reine du pétrole et le pétrole et
l'énergie reine de l'automobile donc 55
60 % de la demande de pétrole consacré
aux transports avec la plus grande
partie grande partie pour le transport
routier et le pétrole qui fait entre 90
et 95% de ses matches et de l'énergie
dans nos dans nos voitures donc ça va
poser un problème si on a probablement
une contrainte sur l'approvisionnement
pétrolier d'autant plus comme j'aime à
le rappeler que quand on vend une
voiture en chine souvent c'est une
voiture qu'on ne vend plus en europe
puisque on a un effet d'éviction sur la
consommation de pétrole entre les pays
émergents et les pays de l' ocde
développée qu'on voit notamment sur la
consommation de pétrole la consommation
en france de pétrole d'ailleurs baisse
depuis si je dis pas de bêtises 2000
2007 donc qu'est-ce qu'il va falloir
faire et bien contrairement à ce que
tout le monde pense la voiture
électrique n'est pas forcément la
meilleure idée qu'on puisse avoir
puisque cette voiture là on va déplacer
une contrainte qu'on avait sur le
pétrole à une contrainte sur des métaux
d'autres métaux comme peut-être le
lithium que l'on retrouve dans nos
téléphones dans nos ordinateurs qui
travaillent pas forcément les terreur
mais le cobalt par exemple qui rentre
aussi dans la constitution des batteries
et qui ne sont pas forcément des métaux
qui sont très recyclables et surtout
qu'ils sont aussi pâle d'un coût élevé
et donc une des solutions que je que je
proposais que je pousse et la sobriété
en termes de transport ça veut pas dire
de rester chez soi mais ça veut dire
d'avoir des voitures qui sont un peu
moins équipée qui font pas le café qui
vont pas le home cinéma mais qui vous
permettront de vous transporter d'un
point a à un point b et donc je défends
notamment l'idée de la voiture à 500 kg
60 kg parce que finalement quand vous
baisser le poids de la voiture
2 un facteur 2 bat vous diviser sa
consommation d'un facteur 2 ses
émissions de co2 d'un facteur 2 et
toutes ces externalités d'un facteur
déjà venus se sorte de déclic j'avais
fait une conférence avec des gens de
renault qui présentait
qui présente on avait une étude
présentée par le cea qui monte comparer
les émissions de co2 d'une voiture
électrique de une tonne cats avec les
émissions de co2 d'une voiture thermique
de 500 kg et on voyait que la zoé d'une
tonne cat et mettez plus de co2 que la
voiture thermique de 60 kg bonjour et
ferment à la twizy est donc j'ai proposé
poser la question gendronneau quand
est-ce que vous sortez votre twizy en
mode thermique et là ils m'ont pas
répondu francis perrin c'est vrai que
l'on est sur la question des transports
et comme le rappelait nicolas meilhan et
olivier appert on est au coeur
évidemment de 2
du business pétrolier très clairement au
niveau mondial pour ce qui est des
transports et notamment transport
routier donc on sait très bien depuis
longtemps que techniquement il ya
plusieurs solutions mais jamais qu'une
solution sur le plan technique au brésil
on a des voitures alcool sans bon sens
dont les voitures électriques ça existe
des véhicules au gaz ma des bus y
compris à paris qui roulent au gaz pour
la ratp xdrive darabont ya les
biocarburants il ya les voitures
hybrides
mais cela dit ce que vient de dire nico
nommé en mai sont particulièrement
importants et demi je pense qu olivia a
péri reviendra c'est que le
les pétroliers et les constructeurs
automobiles
n'ont pas dit leur dernier mot en la
matière ils n'attendent pas passivement
les embêter on va se laisser manger nos
parts de marché par les voitures
électriques par ci part ça ils ont ils
se battent sais pas d'ailleurs
d'aujourd'hui pour améliorer les
performances des véhicules automobiles
depuis de nombreuses années les
résultats ont été spectaculaires
on a en france le programme de litres au
cent je me souviens plus que l'échéance
que je olivia perdra mais voilà donc on
se rend compte à quel point ce couple
pétrole à travers essence ou gazole et
automobile est susceptible encore donc
la voiture telle qu'on la connaît mais
amélioré mais plus légère et à et
susceptibles encore d'amélioration après
des améliorations tout à fait constante
au cours des dernières années même on va
dire depuis les années 70 depuis les
champs pétroliers il ya eu des périodes
où ça a été plus rapidement à bndes et
constamment on améliorer les rendements
l'efficacité et il ya encore une marge
de manoeuvre devant nous dont il ya
d'autres carburants carburants
alternatifs ou les solutions
alternatives qui vont jouer leur rôle
mais je pense que probablement pendant
encore un certain temps et bien les
voitures que l'on connaît aujourd'hui
les véhicules routiers qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui
on aura toujours de l'essence et du
gazole mais avec des rendements et des
performances et donc évidemment moins de
moins d'émissions moins d'impact sur
l'environnement des coûts plus
intéressant pour le consommateur et on
n'est pas on n'a pas encore fini de de
gravir cette courbe d'expérience avec
des résultats déjà tout à fait
spectaculaire et plus c'est encore à
venir rullier
dans le secteur des transports en fait
il ya une course entre eux la demande de
mobilité qui augmente et puis le progrès
technique qui fait baisser les
consommations unitaires
la demande de mobilité
ces mobilités des personnes aussi
n'oublions pas la mobilité des
marchandises le transport de
marchandises représente une part
importante de la demande d'énergie et
elle croit elle croit cet été enfin il
ya une corrélation entre l'augmentation
du
pib et puis sanctionné rejeté la
consommation la consommation énergétique
la demande la demande de mobilité
dans et c'est vrai essentiellement dans
le vrai dans tous les pays alors il y a
à côté de ça il ya une course avec le
progrès technique parce que le progrès
technique effectivement comme
le
disait que vous le disiez avant il y a
des possibilités tout à fait
considérable de baisser la consommation
et puis aussi de trouver de développer
d'autres alternatives baisser la
consommation
aujourd'hui une voiture de milieu de
gamme consomme 4 6 litres aux cent
l'objectif est de mettre sur le marché
un véhicule commercial non pas un
concept car mais un véhicule commercial
qui en 2020 sera sur le marché à des
conditions à des conditions compétitives
à et qui consommera 2 litres aux cent et
là c'est une
multiplication de la mise en oeuvre de
plusieurs technologies l'hybridation
notamment sur avoir une motorisation
électrique et une motorisation thermique
il y à aussi
l'aérodynamisme et puis il ya la
réduction du poids qui joue un rôle
important aujourd'hui la voiture de qui
consomment 80 e 6300 elle pèse une tonne
cas de quoi en moyenne et l'objectif
c'est la voiture de 2 litres au sort de
deux litres aux cent elle doit peser 800
kg ce terreau c'est le poids de la 4l
j'ai choisi vous en venez à 4 l à dien
aussi vous trouvez pas que c'est prendre
le problème dans le mauvais sens je sais
pas si dans le match sans complexe et
c'est comme ça que le progrès technique
évolue et donc les industriels c'est ce
sont les projets que les industriels
mettent en oeuvre faisant les musiques
rouge juste au micro
on va traiter la question de la sobriété
énergétique et de l'optimisation de la
consommation énergétique sur les modes
de transport avec jacques blamont
fondateur du programme spatial français
j'invite nos auditeurs allaient voir une
toute première vidéo qui est traité de
ce sujet là je voudrais en venir aux
au problème de la consommation et de la
baisse de la consommation de mode de
transport regardez l'inde là ils ont des
voitures qui consomment 2 litres au cent
mais ils sont 24 à l'intérieur c'est les
optimise alors c'est pas des voitures
c'est des tricycles les indiens n'ont
pas encore ma voiture et avait plein de
choses ans et surtout
l'optimisation des modes de transport
peut être fait dans l'autre sens c'est à
dire vous voyez cuba ces criminels et
vous êtes passible de peine de prison si
vous ne prenez pas un auto-stoppeur vous
connaissez pourquoi cuba étaient obligés
de développer ce genre de mesures est ce
que vous ne pensez pas que l'aspect
social pourrait en plus de
l'optimisation de la consommation
énergétique des voitures pourrait en
plus nous aider vc pas exclusif c'est
presque ziff mais vous vous je n'ai pas
vous m'avez pas laisser les laisser
terminer je ne sont pas que tu là ce que
je dis c'est que le progrès technique
toute façon il est en marche et le
progrès technique va conduire à une
baisse de la consommation unitaire alors
après combien grade véhicule ça dépend
quand même éventuellement du pib ça
dépend aussi d'évolution du pib ça
dépend de politique des politiques de
transport qui sont mises en oeuvre et là
effectivement le progrès technique ne
règle pas tout et si on développe aussi
des énergies alternatives et francis
perrin il ya fait allusion
à ce moment là c'est le gaz naturel
diverses formes de gaz naturel s'est
vendu ses les biocarburants par exemple
à ce moment là on est dans une situation
où on va atteindre dans à une échéance
qui est peut-être de 20 ou 30 ans un
pile de demande pétrolière
il était avant on parlait du pic de
l'offre du peak oil jay peak de l'offre
aujourd'hui ce qui ce qui est en train
de se dessiner avec cette conjonction du
progrès technique et des politiques qui
sont mises en oeuvre c'est une c'est une
un plafonnement de la consommation de
pétrole nicolas vaillant là moi je
voulais évidemment j'ai envie de
rebondir sur ce point là mais juste pour
clore le chapitre mobilité je veux le
dire que deux litres au cent c'est
quelque chose qu'on prévoit de faire en
2001 mais qu'on a fait en 1946 avec la
mathis andro qu'on a refait en 1980
juste avant avec la renault vestas deux
donc c'est quelque chose qu'on sait
faire mais ce qu'on sait pas faire c'est
avec le niveau de confort actuel des
voitures donc demain alors le programme
de litres 102,2 deux voitures une
voiture qui est dont le développement
était dirigée par psa et sur la
technologie hybride r demain je crois
que ces technologies et ne sera plus
développés puisque dong feng a choisi de
ne pas investir dans la technologie et
l'autre technologie développée par
renault en voiture électrique la
prolongation d'autonomie le modèle
d'ailleurs que renault
développer donc on verra on verra ce qui
se passe mais 2 litres/100 on sait faire
demain vous allez demain dans 1
concession
aixam vous achetez une voiture qui fait
de l'ide 500 alors elle est moins
confortable elle fait beaucoup de bruit
mais elle fait le même service sur le
second point
sociale c'est assez important parce que
c'est quelque chose qu'on oublie souvent
quand on parle de transport au tir on
pense à l'infrastructure routière on
pense aux routes mais on oublie qu'il ya
des voitures dessus et donc aujourd'hui
en fait on a une infrastructure routière
qui est complètement sous utilisés pour
deux raisons 1 95% du temps les voitures
sont à l'arrêt elle ne roule pas 2 vous
avez à peu près
1,2 personnes par voiture
si si aujourd'hui vous augmentez vous
partagez les voitures au lieu de les
utiliser 5 % du temps vous les utilisez
40 % de leur temps ça existe déjà
autopartage autolib ça parle à tout le
monde l'autopartage entre particuliers
et si vous faites du covoiturage c'est à
dire au lieu d'être tout seul dans votre
voiture vous montez à deux personnes par
voiture vous avez une infrastructure
dont taux d'occupation peut passer de 1
5% donc c'est 5 % x 30 % de taux
d'occupation de voitures à 15% donc un
facteur 10 donc aujourd'hui la solution
du transport de demain c'est d'optimiser
ce réseau de transport existants qui est
sous-exploité parce que quand vous
multipliez son efficacité par disque
bien évidemment vous diviser la
consommation d'énergie par dix et donc
ça c'est le plus grand le plus grand
levier il suffit de s'intéresser on a la
chance chez nous d'avoir le champion
mondial du covoiturage blaquart qui a
racheté récemment son principal
concurrent allemand carpooling qui s'est
implanté en inde qui annonçait encore
aujourd'hui son implantation au mexique
et je crois que le covoiturage notamment
sur le trajet domicile travail qui est
là où il ya tous les bouchons et sans
doute la solution la plus efficace c'est
à dire plus que les technologies les
changements de comportement francis
perrin
olivier appert disait il ya quelques
minutes que ce sont deux éléments qui ne
s'opposent pas et je crois que c'est ça
qui est le plus important l'homme on a
tout à fait raison de mettre l'accent
sur des questions de politique publique
en matière de transport
de comportement des personnes le
comportement des personnes ça ne se
décrète pas cependant il faut pas
oublier alors on peut bien sûr être
l'hypothèse mais je pense qu'aucun trois
nuls ne l'est jamais caricaturer les
choses où on a un état qui va dire vous
faites comme si vous faites comme ça
vous prenez trois personnes etc sinon
bon ça se passe pas forcément comme ça
en france en 2015 et dans d'autres pays
donc il faut il ya des campagnes de
sensibilisation il ya de l'information
il ya le ce que ça n'a évoqué ni que la
maison des choses qui n'existaient pas
autopartage c'était intéressant de condé
au début de quelque chose ça produit des
effets sans produira plus à l'avenir
mais on est obligé sur des problèmes
aussi complexes que les problèmes
énergétiques
il n'y a pas une solution ya pas un
bouton sur lequel on appuie et puis les
gens se mettent au garde à vous donc il
faut être sur plusieurs fronts
l'avantagent entre guillemets du progrès
technique qui en a plusieurs c'est que
même si les gens ne changent pas de
comportement ce qu'il souhaite a par
ailleurs pour différentes pour
différentes raisons et pas seulement
d'ailleurs en matière de consommation
d'énergie en matière de sécurité
routière et quelque chose même si les
gens ne changent pas de comportement
vous avez une baisse des consommations
unitaires des véhicules et ça c'est pas
quelque chose ce n'est pas de la science
fiction on le voit depuis des années et
des années
pas con neel voir donc voilà nous avons
besoin je pense de ces deux éléments on
a raison de les évoquer les deux
d'insister sur leur importance mais pas
donné pas de les opposer
je crois qu'il est important de
considérer l'impact des nouvelles
technologies des nouveaux modes de
comportement c'est ce que j'appelle
l'effet gaffard google apple facebook
amazon et le par exemple google a
annoncé avec fierté et avec grand fracas
des google cars à dole a aussi annoncé
l'appel car et donc la mle la prise en
compte de la puissance de ces des
réseaux sociaux de la puissance des
technologies de contrôle commande de la
puissante du big data tout ça peut quand
même changé a révolutionné le rêve le
sait mais quel prix je deviens une santé
j'ai fait une prospective sur les taxis
circulent en préparant cette émission je
me suis intéressé au problème des gaffes
à gogo qui met en route un système de
ballons fournissons l'internet
pratiquement gratuitement et en somme la
planète des ballons à l'hélium avec un
diamètre de 25 m l'aspect des big data
pour travailler dans une société
au fait ce genre de questions vous aurez
vous aurez des voitures automatiques
une homme autonome merci on va vous
aurez des pressions des voitures
autonomes en plus de ces voitures auto
vous aurez grâce au big data la capacité
d'appeler ses voitures autonomes partout
dans le monde après à quel prix humain
cdrs conte au prix de d'éradiquer toute
une caste de taxi qui a payé sa licence
de seraing et l'euro est ce que on est
prêts socialement parlant à cette casse
socialement et politiquement socialement
et politiquement parlant est ce que nous
sommes prêts à avoir ce type de
comportement posez la question aux
politiques un mois ce que je souligne
c'est qu'il y a quand même des game
change eur et que gaza est en game
'changer danse le domaine de
l'automobile une belle bagnole avant ça
se construisait autour d'un moteur le
moteur c'était la pièce maîtresse demain
la bagnole elle se construira autour de
votre iphone et tous tout sera conçu en
fait sombre vous avez un truc j'ai un
mobile
et donc ça c'est véritablement un gain
de change eur qui préoccupe qui
préoccupe beaucoup les constructeurs
automobiles general motors a intégré
justement ses dimensions ils ont décidé
de créer une filiale dédiée justement à
au véhicule connecté aux véhicules
autonomes ils n'ont pas créé des 3 et
l'ancrer dans la silicon valley et donc
ça c'est effectivement un des meneurs
après bon est-ce que ou beurre entre
rumeurs et les taxis effectivement on
peut légiférer
simplement après il y aura la force
jennir delà de la demande et puis
l'impact positif toujours sur ce ces
réseaux d'auto partage dans une indique
dans une ville en afrique alors il n'y a
pas d'infrastructures il n'y a pas de
réseau de transport il faut les
amplifier en afrique lvd le je crois que
ça nous et ab à abidjan rim semble à ce
moment là grâce à la puissance des
réseaux sociaux
à ce moment là se sont se sont créés et
au niveau des prêts à facebook se sont
créés des réseaux structurés d'auto
partage avec des délits naturellement il
ya des lignes voilà et çà et là je pense
que la population en profite
on aura peut-être l'occasion d'y revenir
on vous invitera sur ceux sur les
questions de transversalité entre big
data et modes de transports nicolas
médian brut us pour rebondir sur les sur
les voitures autonomes qui vous
remplacez les chauffeurs de taxi ils
vont remplacer les chauffeurs de taxi et
les chauffeurs de hubert il faut quand
même préciser donc c'est là où on est
sur deux business qui appartiennent à
google est en fait qu'ils sont qu'ils
sont concurrents juste j'ai évoqué plus
tôt le problème du taux d'occupation des
voitures qui est de une virgule un
personnes par voiture
un sénateur je laisse krattinger avait
fait le calcul qu'en augmentant ce taux
d'occupation de 10 % donc en passant de
1,1 à peu près 1,3 ou supprimer
l'ensemble des bouchons des bouchons
donc plus de bouchons et on le comprend
bien puisque l'or l'emprise au sol d'une
voiture pour une personne et une fois
supérieure à celle à celle d'un vélo
mais donc finalement si on pense à ces
robots ces voitures autonomes le but
c'est qu'elle vous conduire tout seul
donc le taux d'occupation se sera pas
1,1 ce sera pas deux ce sera zéro il ya
quand même de fortes chances que ces
voitures autonomes ne bouge pas bloqué
dans les bouchons je pense que c'est un
point qui va être qui est souvent
oubliée la voiture autonome source est
la deuxième voiture électrique si vous
voulez les gens avaient la voiture
électrique de plus années 2000 les
constructeurs automobiles surfer sur la
voiture électrique et puis aujourd'hui
on voit que finalement la voiture
électrique ça représente 0 5% des ventes
quand on donne dix mille euros à
quelqu'un pour l'acheter et donc il se
trouvait un autre cheval qui est la
voiture qui conduit toute seule et moi
personnellement je suis très sceptique
alors ma voiture conduit déjà un peu
tout seul quand j'ai mon régulateur de
vitesse sur l'autoroute ça me suffit si
demain elle conduit un peu plus et ça
existe si j'avais lu mercedes classe s
tant mieux mais je ne crois pas que
demain dans nos villes nouvelles des
voitures autonomes conduire tout seul
que ce soit en 2015 en 2020 en 2025 ou
plus tard francis perrin j'ai le même
scepticisme
je crois que bon c'est très important de
pouvoir évoquer différentes options dans
tous les domaines technologiques pas
seulement les transports dont nous
parlons actuellement on sait très bien
que voilà il ya plusieurs pistes qui a
décidé des concepts des projets et puis
on a pas mal qui vont et jouer l'un qui
ne dépasseront jamais un stade et puis
on a eu deux trois selon le cas qui vont
qui vont héberger qui vont se développer
donc là on est dans un foisonnement
d'idées de concepts c'est très bien
mais je crois ont uni s'est précédemment
que la voiture thermique classique entre
images classiques et classique mais pas
classique parce qu'évidemment elle
bénéficiera d'un ensemble
d'améliorations nous avons évoqué
notamment en termes de réduction de
poids l'hybridation et là encore de très
beaux jours devant elle et que c'est une
solution qui est réaliste parce que il
ya l'aspect technologique et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on peut faire énormément
de choses en matière technologique
ensuite il ya l'aspect économique parce
que c'est bien pour les technologies
mais encore faut-il pouvoir se la payer
alors il ya bien sûr voilà des primes
extra et puis quand l'état n'a plus rien
dans les caisses les primes les
subventions elles disparaissent et et
puis il ya aussi les habitudes des
consommateurs
aujourd'hui on sait ce que c'est qu'une
voiture qui fonctionne à l'essence ou au
gazole
la voiture électrique et les gens qui me
disent ah oui mais j'ai peur d'être en
panne en pleine nuit sur l'autoroute
parce que je crois pas de quoi recharger
alors que la plupart des déplacements
c'est bien que les gens font pas des
centaines de kilomètres ils font parfois
5 km ils vont pas tomber en panne donc
il faut trouver des solutions
réalistes qui allie des progrès
technologiques des progrès
environnementaux la compétitivité
économique et puis qui soit pour
lesquels il ya une demande
ne déstabilise pas complètement le
comportement des gens l'inertie des
consommateurs des personnes de chacun
d'entre nous quand on parle comme ça on
évoque plein de choses ensuite dans nos
comportements quotidiens ne change pas à
180° de comportement parfois
malheureusement parfois heureusement
donc voila tout on a ce foisonnement
c'est très bien on a les gens qu'on
plein d'idées mais dans les années qui
viennent et pas seulement dans les deux
trois ans qui viennent mais je dirais
pour reprendre l'horizon qu'évoquait
nicolas meilhan 5 10 15 ans qui viennent
je crois que voilà on aura des solutions
classiques mais nettement améliorée qui
vont largement dominé et qui
entraîneront des progrès en termes de
rendement de bastille consommations
unitaires et ce sera toujours bon à
prendre il ya la question ensuite bien
sûr des comportements de l'aspect
l'aspect social mais il faut pas
enterrer trop vite des taxis parce que
en france quand même je veux dire dans
ce pays dès qu'un gouvernement faire une
réforme et qu'il ya des personnes dans
la rue il retire la réforme le lendemain
non pensée parce qu'il ya eu baer parce
qu'il ya six parce que ça que les taxis
vont disparaître ça je n'y crois pas du
tout non ils vont se battre logiquement
sont possibles mais socialement et
politiquement avant disparaît grand
diseur ont bloqué roissy une demie froid
et une pendant trois heures
n'importe quel gouvernement a déjà pris
le taxi à new york oui mais il ya un
petit peu de temps déjà oui mais et vous
n'avez pas remarqué en fait que les
populations de new york qui utilisent le
taxi ou qui font taxi ce sont des
populations qui souffrent c'est à dire
que moi j'appelle ça ce pakistanais
était donc avant de disparaître c'est
sûr que les taxis font ce pakistanais
était un petit peu c'est à dire que la
la baisse de leurs revenus ce sera sera
importante après je ne sais pas s'ils
prendront d'assaut à l'elysée l'aéroport
au paris on verra bien
intéressant sur les taxis c'est que vous
avez moi j'étais récemment dans un
hubert et donc c'était un ancien
chauffeur de taxi donc il a revendu sa
licence moins cher moins chers puisque
les prix ont baissé de 10 à 20% et il
est devenu chauffeur über avec sa propre
voiture et donc vous avez un certain
nombre de taxis qui vont assez bien
évidemment il vous revendre leur licence
y aura sans doute des gens pour acheter
vous avez essayé des sciences qui vont
donc on va baisser petit à petit il y
aura un sujet à régler par le
gouvernement c'est important juge et un
carton j'aimerais olivier appert la
paire nous pas un petit peu quand même à
bord la levée la voiture autonome
bon c c'est de la com mais la voiture
autonome aussi c'est une réalité et ce
tir grâce aux progrès techniques dont
j'ai pas mal parlé il est possible de
faire beaucoup de choses il est possible
effectivement les limiteurs de vitesse
et tout ça on peut aujourd'hui par
exemple la voiture peut se garer toute
seule sans aucun sans aucun problème
de là on peut faire de l'aide à la
conduite et ça effectivement ça
apportera quand même un service de là à
aller vers le véhicule autonome qui se
conduira tout seul ça risque quand même
de poser des problèmes relatifs aux
assurances à mon avis pas évident du fbi
inquiétez pas à google heures à 500
patience
oui mais laura après vous décider des
dates avec l'habitacle derrière mais
qu'est ce que le même album golf et
google car c'est tout simplement parce
que par le biais justement de ces
véhicules connectés ça leur permet de
récupérer des données qui sont
extrêmement importantes et après de les
revendre c'est un enjeu qui est majeur
quand même pour les constructeurs
automobiles de savoir comment les
véhicules sont utilisés et donc de
pouvoir envoyer le bon message en disant
votre bagnole ça fait quand même vous
avez dépassé là la limite pour vos pneus
pour votre en voyage il faut le changer
donc google on comprend pourquoi ils
vont pas construire des véhicules
simplement il développe cette idée parce
que ça leur permet vont investir dans ce
domaine là parce que ça leur permettra
effectivement de
développer leur accès à des données et
de vendre ces données après et de
capturer une part du gâteau du gâteau
des constructeurs automobiles qui
aujourd'hui ne veulent pas partager des
informations mais google ainsi on prend
bmw récemment qui a refusé de partager
les informations des informations etc
ces gens là moi je suis je suis sur la
sur la même longueur d'onde 1 que les
olivier appert concernant ses voitures
alors il ya une réglementation
européenne
et oblige aujourd'hui pour que notre
compte une voiture roule d'avoir les
mains sur le volant donc il va falloir
quand même la changer si on veut que la
voiture roule tout seul
oui je roule je j'ai ma voiture qui est
qui est autonome est-ce que vous avez
des voitures d'ailleurs donc moi je j'ai
une voiture hybride diesel hybride qui
est effectivement est très performante
parce que dans une conduite en ville ça
permet quand même d'économiser 30% de la
consommation et c'est ce qui fait partie
justement de ces gains de productivité
mais je conduis ma voiture autonome et
puis il ya un gamin qui traverse à ce
moment là c'est la voiture qui décident
d'écraser le gamin ou qui décide
d'envoyer la bagnole dans dans le décor
ces raisons d écraser s'écraser la
grand-mère ou est-ce que vous écrasez le
gamin voilà où alors vous voulez sur une
route à deux à 200 c vous devez dépasser
un vélo et si vous le si vous les
croisez pas vous vous prenez la voiture
en face toujours un choix délicat d'en
parler
je vais vous poser deux dernières
questions parce que l'heure tourne quand
même on n'a pas vu le temps passer
je vous préviens de la dernière tout de
suite pour par vaux en traître la
dernière question ce sera laissé une
bouteille à la mer sur internet pour les
jeunes générations un conseil dans une
bouteille sur les réseaux en vain vous
vendre immortel ce soir et la question
juste avancer vous avez une minute pour
me dire ce que vous voulez on va
commencer par nicolas meilhan et en une
minute
moi je pense qu'ils les idées on en a
pas parlé mais il est crucial que nous
que nos représentants comprennent
l'enjeu lié au pétrole et au gaz
aujourd'hui ils pensent que nucléaire
renouvelable
mais ce pétrole et ce gaz 1 nous
l'achetons à vladimir poutine pour une
grande partie sur un peu mois en france
prône condamné ou dans l'esprit sommes
un peu moins en france mais un nouveau
européen c'est à peu près 30%
approvisionnements et
seconde lancée cet approvisionnement
cette disponibilité nous allons en avoir
moins par personne ce qui est
intéressant comme exemple je le cite
souvent c'est cuba cuba est le seul pays
au monde qui a déjà passé le pic
pétrolier ils n'ont pas si en 1990
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait sur le
transport notamment ils se sont mis à
produire 500 mille vélos et ils en ont
fait importer de chine et ils ont
développé des normes bus sur des semi
remorques qu'on appelle des chameaux
pour pouvoir transporter les gens je
pense qu'il est temps que l'on s'oriente
et qu'on regarde ces pays qui ont mis en
place ces solutions de sobriété car les
vraies solutions viennent des pays
pauvres qui ont peu d'énergie à
disposition de madagascar à être un très
bon exemple francis perrin une minute
pour rebondir sur cuba compte tenu de ce
qui se passe actuellement du
rapprochement des états unis je pense
que dans quelques temps cuba fera venir
des compagnies pétrolières notamment
américaines pour explorer dans l'espoir
de trouver du pétrole et du gaz au large
des côtes de l'île c'est déjà en
négociation mais jadis ce n'est pas ce
que dit nicolas médian est juste mais on
est dans un climat dans un contexte très
particulier il ya un embargo et serra
qui induit des comptes mondy politique
je ne suis pas sûr qu'elle dure
forcément longtemps à cuba dans quelque
temps mais sur le fond je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec lui la question de
l'utilisation la plus efficace possible
l'énergie est un aspect fondamental de
tout ça devrait être un aspect
fondamental douter les politiques
énergétiques je crois que le pic de
production du pétrole il est pas pour
demain il est pas pour après-demain et
on a encore beaucoup ce sera pas infini
mais on a on n'aura pas de problème
avant longtemps la matière mais quelle
que soit cette ce fameux big ben est
trop dit ou pas on a intérêt pays
consommateurs pays producteurs a tenté
d'économiser le pétrole et l'énergie de
la façon la plus intelligente possible
et je crois que ça devrait être vraiment
la priorité de toutes les politiques
énergétiques
je suis par ailleurs aussi d'accord avec
ce que disait nicolas meilhan en france
malheureusement va malheureusement on
pense hydraulique énergie en oeuvre
n'est clair énergies renouvelables c'est
très bien mais on oublie quand même que
le pétrole et le gaz ça existe encore
donc apparemment selon certains discours
politiques on fait comme si ça n'existe
pas mais on l'a rappelé les combustibles
fossiles pétrole gaz charbon c'est 80%
de la consommation mondiale d'énergie
primaire aujourd'hui et selon les
prévisions de l'agencé s'installe de
l'énergie qu'évoquait olivier appert
tout à l'heure vers 2040 encore 75% donc
il faut quand même faire face aux
réalités comme disait le camarade marx
si on veut transformer le monde il fonde
et commencer par le comprendre c'est pas
ennuyant certaines réalités qu'on fait
bonne politique énergétique
olivier appert je trouve un peu
paradoxal de prendre comme exemple cuba
mais cuba n'a pas abandonné
l'exploration pétrolière et gérard
depardieu aussi avaient investi en son
temps dans une compagnie pétrolière qui
faisaient de l'exploration à cuba
bon froid le le conseil à donner c'est
essayer de rationaliser les débats les
débats dans le domaine de l'énergie sont
beaucoup trop passionné c'est pour
répondre c'est beaucoup trop caricatural
beaucoup trop politiquement correct
faisant preuve de pragmatisme et là les
anglais sur ce plan là il nous donne des
leçons
mais c'est pas très politiquement
correct de dire de prendre l'exemple de
l'autre côté deux côtés de sa majesté
deuxième point je crois qu'on ne peut
pas dépenser sans compter c'est à dire
que il faut aujourd'hui compter voir
combien ça coûte et prendre en compte le
fait qu' il faut choisir des options qui
sont quand même pas trop trop cher et
commencer par investir sur les
technologies ça va investir à faire les
choix qui sont à l'intérieur ça bouge en
interne oui alors vous êtes au courant
de votre dernière question mais je vais
faire une petite transition juste avant
donc la question s'est laissé un conseil
aux jeunes générations sur internet et
pour recevoir vos réponses je vais
laisser exceptionnellement mon micro aux
personnes qui nous héberge aujourd'hui
c'est à dire dissemblances un jeune
magazine qui a été fondée par bande de
copains jeunes
je vous pose la question nicolas meilhan
vous au répondait en premier et je
laisse ma chaise à dissemblances
nicolas on voit le conseil pour les
jeunes générations le conseil pour les
jeunes générations
mais
économistes pour acheter un vélo
ça c'est tout ça que les conseils fait
que vous attendez pas
[Musique]
une conseil serait mais c'est pas
seulement pour les jeunes générations
on en a parlé largement aujourd'hui
l'énergie c'est fondamental pour plein
de raisons
sur le plan économique sur le plan
industriel sur le plan politique sur le
plan de la vie des populations
donc il faut s'y intéresser ça paraît
très complexe et encore plus complexe
s'emparait mais c'est pas une raison
pour ne pas poser ces questions-là
s'intéressent tous les citoyens se doit
pas être réservée aux gouvernements aux
compagnies pétrolières aux compagnies
gazières aux énergéticiens ils ont leur
rôle à jouer bien sûr
et leurs points de vue a donné dans ces
débats mais on a vraiment besoin de
débat citoyen dans le meilleur sens du
terme est l'un des problèmes de ce pays
c'est que sur certains sujets délicats y
compris des questions énergétiques on ne
sait pas on arrive pas on ne veut pas
savoir comment organiser de vrais débats
sur les vraies questions
tout à fait d'accord sur la nécessité de
d'organiser des débats de pouvoir
débattre là encore les anglais nous
donne des exemples le conseil que je
donnerais c'est d'éteindre la lumière en
sortant de la pièce et ça je veux dire
j'ai des petites filles et je constate
que ce réflexe est complètement disparu
et si on est un palais lumière en
sortant de la pièce à ce moment là je
crains quand même que tous les discours
que l'on a sur l'efficacité énergétique
sur la sobriété ce soit uniquement du
vent
merci beaucoup bonjour andré y sommes
pour un dissemblances un journal qui a
été lancée il ya deux jours
à destination des 15 25 ans mais aussi
des autres
je vais vous poser une dernière question
ou plutôt de questions donc vous avez
beaucoup parlé d'eux je sais pas s'ils
sont existe mais de la macro énergie et
c'était très intéressant mais ma
question porte sur la micro énergie je
sais pas ça existe par exemple il ya
deux semaines j'ai pris pour la première
fois de ma vie une tesla et d'un point
de vue utilisateur j'ai eu l'impression
que c'est la voiture du futur j'ai
trouvé ça vraiment formidable de tout
point de vue est-ce que ça fait pas de
bruit fait ce que ça va vite parce que
pour des raisons sûrement bête est
futile mais d'un point de vue
utilisateur ça m'a donné cette
impression
donc je vais vous demander ce que vous
en pensez
voilà d'un point de vue utilisateur et
pas d'un point de vue purement rationnel
où on met les gens en fait dans des bus
ou dans des cars vous pour rationaliser
la situation
peut-être pour commencer sur la tesla a
figuré où je vais aussi essayer de
semaine donc on a failli se croisent et
si c'était à gennevilliers à la
concession la tesla c'est une ferrari
qui fait pas de bruit donc effectivement
et ça c'est le principal avantage de la
voiture électrique c'est le silence
c'est le silence parce qu'on vit dans un
univers urbain on s'en est rendu compte
aujourd'hui où le bruit est ultra
stressant et donc la voiture électrique
son silence c'est son principal avantage
la tesla est une voiture on avait parlé
de poids du poids moyen d'une voiture de
une tonne 3 la tesla avec une voiture
qui pèse deux tonnes d'oeufs et qui
embarquent 700 kg de batteries et qui
consomment l'équivalent en énergie
primaire d'une voiture qui pèse une
tonne 6 d'accord et donc elle est
souvent occupé plus tôt par une personne
et donc sur notre problème de
consommation d'énergie elle va l'empiré
sachant que derrière elle va en plus
embarquer une quantité d'énergie
impressionnante de batteries pour quelle
raison parce que vous avez 100 fois plus
d'énergie dans un kilo de pétrole que
dans 1 kg de batteries et c'est la
raison pour laquelle aujourd'hui les
voitures électriques représentent 0 5%
du marché et que ce sera le cas demain
aussi et surtout après demain on coupera
les subventions de 10000 euros pour
subventionner une solution alors c'est
intéressant et c'est cela c'est que
quand vous avez vous êtes c'est des gens
plutôt riche parce que c'est ken 75000
euros vous avez quand même le droit
aussi 1300 euros de déductions qui à mon
sens est un scandale sans nom
alors je n'ai pas conduit une tesla donc
en termes du point de vue de
l'utilisateur je ne peux pas en parler
cela dit le raisonnement que vient donc
de présenter
nicolas meilhan me semble parfaitement
juste on je ne peux que kiki souscrire
je n'ai pas grand chose à ajouter sinon
pour sur un autre plan vous souhaitez
vous dire bravo pour le lancement
dissemblances c'est pas facile de lancer
une publication aujourd'hui j'en sais
quelque chose et longue vie j'espère à
cette nouvelle nouvelle publication
vous avez apprécié à l'été sam est ce
que vous allez l'acheter un retour pour
la petite anecdote c'était humber tesla
en plus j'ai pas de conduite moi même
bon je crois que le tesla s'est
effectivement intéressant comme concept
avec une performance parlant type
technique en fait il y à des
performances en termes d'autonomie qui
sont quand même intéressante et qui sont
bien supérieurs qui sont deux fois
supérieures aux véhicules électriques
qu'on trouve
et renouveau gbm chez nissan etc par
contre le business model n'est quand
même pas pas évident
et à mon avis ça correspond à un marché
plus de niches
de un petit peut jaillir de bobos qui
peuvent se payer une voiture de 75 à 100
mille euros
et bon qui en ont besoin pour aller de
neuilly à saint germain
d'accord mais vous avez vos quêtes de
choses qui étaient le prix et que ça
représentait que 0 5% du marché mais
est-ce que c'est pas la même chose pour
la voiture thermique d'or de son
invention en fin de sa mise en
commercialisation
alors le problème de la voiture
électrique si vous voulez et c'est le
problème d'un consommateur vous allez
changer pour un autre produit seulement
s'il est mieux pour moins cher la
voiture électrique est plus cher et
éléments bien et en fait son autonomie
qui est née limiter qu'à 200 km alors 80
% des trajets journalistes sont 50 km
mais le problème c'est les 20 % et le
problème c'est même le trajet vous
partez en vacances parce que vous avez
pas forcément les moyens d'avoir deux
voitures aujourd'hui la voiture
électrique est cantonné à un rôle de
seconde voiture pas de bol la seconde
voiture est cantonné à un rôle de
voitures d'occasion est très cher donc
aujourd'hui telle qu'elle est avec son
autonomie limitée à 200 km la voiture
électrique ne peut pas s'imposer sur le
marché par contre vous allez une
solution qui va se développer très
fortement tirée par le groupe volkswagen
qui est la voiture autonomie électrique
à autonomie prolongée ou hybrides
rechargeables qui vous permet d'avoir
une batterie qui fait qu'ils couvrent 50
km dont 80% du temps vous rouler sans
pétrole et sur les 20 % du temps restant
vous avez un petit prolongateur
d'autonomie qui n'est rien qu'un groupe
électrogène qui vous permet de recharger
votre batterie et de rouler 500 km et
donc de partir en vacances où vous
voulez
aux quatre coins de la france il n'y a
aucun doute sur le fait que pratiquement
aucun doute sur le fait que
l'industrialisation des voitures
électriques est une production de masse
permettra évidemment entraînerait une
baisse des coûts et des prix le problème
c'est est-ce que ça va arriver et quand
et pour les raisons que je viens
d'évoquer nicolas meilhan est ce que ce
déclic en termes de consommation va se
produire avec là encore le consommateur
la technologie c'est bien une voiture
silencieuse c'est très bien
l'impact sur l'environnement c'est très
bien mais ensuite il regarde son
portefeuille et alors il ya ces
subventions mais voilà c'est ce qui le
ce qu'il en est je crois qu'il ya pas
beaucoup de gens en france qui se font
qu'ils sont l'illusion que les
subventions promises aujourd'hui par tel
ou tel gouvernement vont durer pendant
très longtemps quand on voit l'état des
finances publiques françaises d'autres
sujets qui n'est pas énergétique mais
qu'il faut qu'il faut garder en tête
et par ailleurs on l'évoquait
précédemment dans notre débat nous avons
des voitures thermiques
essence ou diesel qui sont bien connues
des utilisateurs
et qui continue à améliorer constamment
leurs performances
donc voilà est-ce que le consommateur il
dit gg les voitures je connais je sais
comment ça fonctionne et c'est bon les
rendements sont de plus en plus
intéressant et puis par ailleurs j'ai la
voiture électrique qu'à plein de charme
oui mais bon l'écart de prix et puis qui
ciblent donc je suis alors là encore il
faut revenir ce que ce qu'on disait au
début de notre débat en matière
d'énergie à le court terme il ya le long
terme il ya le moyen terme par dont le
long terme il faudra même ajouter le
très long terme donc je ne suis pas en
train de dire que jamais la voiture
électrique ne percera ça dépend quel
horizon de temps mais
sur le court terme évidemment c'est
impossible mais même sur le moyen moyen
long terme je dirais je ne suis pas
persuadé que finalement la voiture entre
guillemets classique mais largement
améliorée parce ces progrès technique
continu et réalisé par les pétroliers et
par les constructeurs automobiles ne
restent pas suffisamment attrayante aux
yeux de la plus grande partie des
consommateurs pendant encore pas mal de
temps nous allons laisser le mot de la
fin aux lilas vert pendant dix neuf sans
cela il y avait une concurrence entre le
véhicule à essence le vécu la vapeur et
le véhicule électrique est à l'époque
c'est le véhicule électrique gagner
c'est la jamais contente qui a dépassé
les 100 kilomètres heure
et il se trouve que malgré cette avance
c'est le véhicule à essence le véhicule
thermique qui a très largement gagné la
course tout simplement à cause de
l'autonomie steira en fait le volume et
le poids par unité d'énergie de
l'essence et du diesel sont sans commune
mesure avec eux vv que la vapeur ou les
véhicules électriques
donc ça c'est un élément et nicolas mais
on en a parlé alors j'ai parlé du
véhicule de litres aux 100 en fait on
parle aussi du véhicule un litre aux 100
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un véhicule un
litre aux cent c'est un véhicule de 2
litres au cent qui est rechargeable et
le litre au cent qu'on économise c'est
précisément de l'électricité et c'est ce
que disait nicolas meilhan
alors n'oublions pas quand on parle de
transport on parle de la voiture parce
que beaucoup de monde je dis pas tout le
monde a sa bagnole mais tout le monde
voit les bagnoles dans les rues
n'oublions pas que au plan de l'énergie
le transport de marchandises représente
entre le tiers et la moitié de la
consommation d'énergie et donc est ce
que vous imaginez que pour transporter
des marchandises on va voir un camion
avec la moitié de la charge qui est en
batterie la charge utile qui est divisé
par deux parce que la moitié du camion
va être utilisée par des batteries donc
là n'oublions pas quand on parle de
transport et quand on parle de pétrole
que là le véhicule individuel ne
représente qu'une partie de la
consommation et les réponses il ya des
réponses aussi technologiques et des
réponses politiques pour les autres pour
les autres secteurs du transport
messieurs je vous remercie dissemblances
vous remercie à très bientôt
[Musique]